[Music]
hi my name is Gemma ask him and I am
Glamour magazine's sex editor I am going
to be writing every week on Glamour calm
about the sex that you're having the
good sex the bad sex
the oh my god I can only talk about this
after three large wine step a sex editor
well it basically means being able to
talk about things like pubes scrotums
dildos and keeping a straight face most
of the time I have been writing about
sex for about a decade I have spoken to
pretty much everyone about sex
sexologists neurologists therapists even
a pubic hair trend forecaster actually a
job it's the best topic in the whole
world to write about until your
grandparents oh I see what you're
writing about and it's probably
something like [ __ ] rings which um isn't
really ideal but it does mean you come
across a lot of weird facts I mean I've
always got a weird sex a semen actually
smells the same as the bean sprouts yeah
apparently it's because they contain a
substance called
spurning sorry I've now ruin the
surprise being for life this week on the
colon I am talking about sex noise sex
has so many noises not all of them the
desirable and this is absolutely one of
the worst because it's shared section
waves when you overhear other people
doing it which happens a lot because
rules are paper-thin and it is just the
most awful feeling ever join in the
discussion share your stories on this
topic or really any other topics that
you want to talk about tell me about the
sex that you're having that you want to
have that's making you laugh what's
making you run anything
thanks so much for listening for more
videos like these please subscribe to
glamour UK below somewhere